نحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد بعد اربعه ايام
على انتخابات منتصف الولايه التي خيبت
امال الجمهوريين اعلن فوز السيناتور ضد
الديمقراطيه كاثرين كورتز في ولايه نيفادا
على المرشح المدعوم من الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب ليصبح مجلس الشيوخ للحزب
الديمقراطي وسيحفظ الديمقراطون على
اغلبيتهم الضيقه في مجلس الشيوخ خلال
العامين المقبلين بعد الانتصارات التي
حققوها في انتخابات ولايتين بعد واريزونا
ليصبحوا عدد الديمقراطين في المجلس 50 من
اصل مئه بينما حصل الجمهوريون على 79 او
49 مقعدا فيما يتبقى مقعده ولايه جورجيا
بانتظار جوله الاعاده فسادس من ديسمبر
المقبل كما سيظل الديمقراطيون قادرين على
اقرار المرشح بعيدا مثل القضاه التينا و
سيشمل ذلك المرشحين المحكمه العليا في
حالات شهور اي مقعد فيها الرئيس الامريكي
قال انه مسرور جدا بنتيجه انتخابات
التجديد النصفي مشددا على ان الانتخابات
عزيزه وضعه السياسيه قبل لقائه نظيره
الصيني اما عن مجلس النواب فلا يزال
الجمهوريون قريبين من انتزع السيطره على
مجلس النواب مع تواصلي فرز الاصوات في
انتخابات التجديد النصفيه
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من اورلاندو
وتوم حرب ريس وتحالف الامريكي للشرق او
الشرق اوسطي للديمقراطيه اهلا بك ومن
واشنطن البحث في الشان الامريكي احمد
الحنطي اهلا
بكمين اسم حالي ان ابدا من واشنطن معك
استاذ احمد استاذ احمد الان وقد تقريبا
الصوره اكتملت فيما يخص حزب فيما يخص مجلس
النواب فما يخص مجلس الشيوخ هل تعتقد بانه
الفتره القادمه او هذه النتائج ستؤثر على
الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه خاصه وان
البعض يتحدث عن ان همم ترامب افسد شكل
الحزب مظهر الحزن وحتى الاهداف وقد يتم
اقصاءه الفتره القادمه من امكانيه ان يكون
مرشحا للانتخابات الرئاسيه
طبعا هناك الكثير مما يمكن ان يقال في هذا
المجال بكل تاكيد يعني الديمقراطيين يعني
حققوا نجاح كبير في هذا الانتخابات ووضعوا
اساس قوي لحملتهم في 24 بينما الحزب
الجمهوري يعني يظهر الان حزب مفكك مقبل
على صراعات كبيره في الفتره القادمه مما
يضرب حظوظه ولكنه لا يمكن الجزم بان يعني
احد الحزبين سينتصر في هذا الفتره مبكرين
جدا ونحن نتكلم عن المنظمات كبيره يعني
لها اساس قويه
نعم حظوظهم اقل بكل تاكيد يعني اصلا دائما
لما يكون عندك رئيس يعاد انتخابه في حظوظه
اكبر في الانتخاب اصلا بدون اي شيء فما
بالك عندما يكون الحزب الجمهوري مقبل على
صراع مرير يعني
بالمعنى المجازي قد يكون صراعمي هذا كله
يضع حظوظه ولكنه في النهايه نتكلم عن حزب
كبير وقوي قادره على المنافسه
خاصه ونحن نتحدث عن ثنائيه تاريخيه ولكن
ااه استاذ توم هل تعتقد بان للجمهوريين حظ
لا زال موجود
لمحاوله على الاقل الظفر بما بقي وما بقي
كبير نتحدث عن رئاسيات القادمه
اول مرحبا لك احمد والمشاهدين هلا طبعا
الجمهوريين رقم حظك كبير
لنتكلم بالوقائع بالنسبه لمجلس الشيوخ كان
هنالك منافسه على 35 مقعدا والجمهوريين
يدافعون عن 29 مقعد لهم هذا الدفاع يعني
حتى اليوم ربما لا يخسرون اي مقعد حسب
نتائج جورج مثل ما تفضلت منذ قليل وانما
الانتخابات القادمه من 2024
جمهوريين يقطعون فقط عن عشر مقاعد واا بين
الديمقراطيين سيكون لهم اكثر من 20 مقعدا
يجب ان يدافعوا عليه وربما الخساره
الكبيره اما الموجه الحمراء ستكون بمجلس
الشيوخ من 2024 اما مجلس النواب صحيح كانت
هناك استطلاعات رايي بانه سيكون هنالك
موجه حمراء ولم تحصل وانما من الواضح
باننا سيحصلون على الاثريه
المطرقه من الحزب الديمقراطي الى الحزب
الجمهوري هلا ولكن هنالك
ستطرح بالسؤال الاول موجه كانت انه
شخصيات ترامب ولكن الواقع الاساسي هو
اليوم همم يجب ان نتحدث كيف حصلت هذه
الانتخابات ولماذا النتائج لم ااه لم نعرف
نهايه النتائج بعد خاصه بدانا بالانتخابات
منذ شهر وليس هنالك نهار واحد يعني اذا بل
يا نصيب الوطني اذا بالمقارنه اليانصيب
الوطني قبل النهائي يعني بسبعه الشهر كان
اكثر من 300 شراء ورقه همم يا نصيب وطني
وبذات الله لا نعرف النتيجه واين المكان
واين الشخص الرابحها ومن هو بقى لماذا
اليوم يعني بالانتخابات
مقدسه الامريكان بقى لم نعرف بعد الحقائق
ويجب اعاده الدرس هذا الملف بالانتخابات
يعالج موضوع ماذا حصل بالداخل وما هي
الاحصاءات ومن صوت لهم ومن لم يصوط لهم
واذا كان بعدين بالنتيجه الرئيس
للانتخابات الاسبوع
القادم الحزب الجمهوري بالانتخابات
التمهيديه يكرر اذا هذا الشخصيه هو
المميزه
يرى الصوره اوضح ما زالك البعض يقول بان
ترامب يتحمل المسؤوليه هذه الخساره او على
الاقل هذا الفوز بطعم الخساره على مستوى
مجلسا وبان الجمهوريين قد يتوجه الى
اقصائه للانتخابات الرئاسيات القادمه
حفاظا اولا على متى كانت الحزب على
اعاده الوحده اللي مختلف اطراف الحزب حتى
لمحاوله الدخول بطريقه فيها اكثر
حظوظفر بانتخابات الرئاسه ما رايك
على نتائج الخطوط الواقع السياسي السياسيه
يعني جمهوريين كانوا مرتاحين لما كان
الرئيس ترامب سده الرئاسه على اربع سنوات
وما اعطى الولايات المتحده والتعامل الدول
يعني كانت تنافس في ذلك الوقت فقط
الميزان القوى الاقتصادي اليوم التعامل
الدولي رايحين ربما على حرب نوويه استعداد
بلدان على سبيل المثال
منذ سنه بالذات كان اجتماع
القمه جي اي 20 مثل ما بنعرفها وكان بوتن
هنالك وتحدث مع الرئيس بارد وكان كل شيء
على ما يراد وبعد شهرين دخل الى اوكرانيا
اليوم الرئيس ماذا تكلم مع الرئيس شيبس
همم الرئيس الصيني ولم نعرف
متغيرات وكل شيء همم يعني ممكن ولكن حضرتك
لا تريد حتى وضع هذه الفرضيه الوجه
الجمهوريه
بيروحوا على انتخابات تمهيديه اذا الشعب
قرر انتخابه مره ثانيه يمثل حزب الجمهوري
لا احد يقدر اقصاء احد بالولايات المتحده
فهذا حقهم وهذا ما يسمح
الاستاذ احمد ما رايكم
على قياده الحزب الجمهوري لتحقيق انتصارات
يعني انتخابيه على مستوى عموم الناخبين
هذه حقيقه واضحه الان في ذهن الجمهوريين
وبالتالي نظريا في يعني دائما في السياسه
عندما تخسر قياده الحزب بهذا الشكل لانه
يتم استبدالها ولكن الاشكاليه التي تواجه
الجمهوريين ان ترامب غير مستعد للتنازل
وانه مستعد يعني هذه سقف المعبد على
الجميع همم
هذا سيضع جمهوريه امام الخيار وضعوا امامه
اكثر من مره يعني في السنوات القليله
الماضيه انه هل نستسلم لضغط ترامب ام ندخل
معه في صراع قد ينتج عنه التمزيق الحزب
يعني لا نتكلم عن تنسيق الحزب بمعنى
انهيار نتكلم عن تنسيق الضمانه
يعني بدرجه كبيره لانه يصبح غير قادر على
تحقيق يعني غير قادر على تحقيق اي ارقام
غريبه مما يمكن ان وحتى وحتى نتائج
الانتخابات همم الكونغرس كانت كذلك دليل
يقول البعض لو لم يكن ترامب حاضر همم كانت
يمكن ان تكون النتيجه مغيره هل توافق هذا
الطرح او لا هناك مبالغه في قول ذلك
بكل تاكيد يعني اهم المقاعد التي خسرها
الجمهوريون في هذه الانتخابات كان كانت
المنافسه عليها من قبل مرشحين مدعومين من
قبل ترامب يعني ترامب هو من اوصلهم لترشيح
الحزب بدعمه وبتركيزه هذا يعني يدل على
انه رغم سيئه ترامب على قواعد الحزب
الجمهوري الا انه يعني شعبيته ضعيفه وهناك
الرفض شعبي يعني نسبه من يرفضونه اعلى من
نسبه من يريدونه بشكل واضح
ذلك
بانه في المقابله همم يعمل وبدا يطرح او
راقه وبدا يستعمل اوراق جد مهم بعضا مؤخرا
بعد على الاقل الاعلان عن هذا النتائج ولو
بصفه اوليه بدا يتحدث في ازمه اوكرانيا
روسيا عن مفاوضات ضروريه في هذه المرحله
همم اليوم تصريحاته توحي بانه هناك تقارب
صيني او على الاقل هو يود ان همم يطرح مثل
هكذا فكره لانه نحن قد على التقارب وهناك
همم مخاطر نحن قادرون على التعامل معها
وبالتالي وكان بيضا كذلك بدا هو نفسه يتخذ
استراتيجيه يمكن ان تكون ناجعه لخوض هذا
في الانتخابات القادمه
بالنسبه لموضوع التفاوض الروسي الاوكراني
هو يعني قرا النتيجه بمجلس النواب وهم
الذين يكررون الميزانيه فيفرضون على شرط
اساسي وهو بدعم تفاوض روسي اوكراني لحل
هذا النزاع وعدم الاستنزاف الدائم وخاصه
الامريكيين يدفعه المنظرهم لدعم اوكرانيا
فهو يصدق يرتبط الامور لهذا الحل بالذات
اما بموضوع السنه نحن نتخوف يعني منذ
شهرين كانت السيده
اليوم طبعا الاجتماع مع الرئيس الصيني ولم
نعرف بعد نتائجها يعني لم يبحثوا موضوع
كورونا لم يبحثوا موضوع تردد الصيني في
عده مجالات خاصه هنا ضمن الولايات المتحده
همم
بالاحتقار الفقري لعده مجالات وهم وهذا لم
يبحثون اهو نحنا بهمنا بنايات مطاف
النتائج على الارض لمصلحه الشعب الامريكي
وليس شعارات الرنانه اما سنعود الى الحزب
الجمهوري الحزب الجمهوري هو الذي دعم
ترامب لتعيين ثلاثه مضاد لمجلس
الذين هم تراجعوا عن همم روفر
اليوم يلومونه لانه نسبه من الشعب راح صوت
ضد هذه الفقره هذا لا يحق لهم القرار
للشعب الامريكي اولا واخيرا في الانتخابات
التمهيديه والانتخابات النهائيه
استاذ احمد في اطار نفسها سؤال هل بدا
يعمل من خلال هذه القمه ومن خلال تصريحات
على الاقل اعطاء صوره همم
تخدموا للانتخابات القادمه او تخدم على
الاقل
نعم بكل تاكيد يعني الرئيس
يعني يحس الان اداره بشكل عام والحزن
الديمقراطيه ان السيف رفع عن رقابتين يعني
هم كانوا مقبلين على ما يمكن ان يكون يعني
مذبحه سياسيه في انتخابات 22 لذلك كانوا
مضغوطين جدا وكانوا يخشون ان السنتين
القادمتين يعني ستكون سنتين صراع مرير بين
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين يعني يقود من
خلال هذه الجمهوريين عمليات تحقيق موسعه
محاولات عزل لعدد من الاعضاء
المجلس الوزراء وتحقيقات كل هذا كان سيشغل
الاداره كثير انه سيجعلهم في موقف ضعف
ومشاكل وغير قادرين على الاداء الان يحسون
ان السيف ارتفع عن رقبتهم لذلك سنرى اداره
يعني غالبا سنرى اداره اداره اكثر راحه
اكثر مرونه اكثر قدره على الحركه وعلى
العمل يعني رايناها مثلا يحاول القاء همم
موضوع التضخم على الخارج يتكلم عن حرب
اوكرانيا
وهذه كلها كانت تخبطات بيسبت ضغط
الانتخابات هذه الامور كلها ستقبل حذتها
كثيرا وستختفي وسنرى اداره بيض قادره على
العمل بمرونه اكثر مع الاصدقاء والاعداء
من لندن حرب رايس وتحالف الامريكي يشرق
قسطنطينيه